a conveyor moves baking trays forward a
machine uses suctioning devices to pick
up paper liners flip them right-side up
and insert them in the baking trays
valves open and dispense the batter in
the hopper into the cupcake liners in
the pans
the system controls the flow of batter
so it only fills the liners one-third of
the way this leaves room for the cake to
rise during baking the pans move through
different levels with a range of
temperature zones over a period of 25
minutes finally emerging from the other
side
[Music]
during baking the cupcakes have risen
above the liner's they now head into a
cooling chamber they stay in here for 20
minutes while fans blow air onto them to
cool them down
[Music]
the cooling firms up the cakes
a robot plunges pin like tentacles into
the cupcakes to lift them out of the
pans with the paper liners attached it
transfers them to the packaging conveyor
line
workers pack them in clamshell plastic
containers a dozen to each one
they leave the containers open because
they still need to decorate these
cupcakes ahead fluffy chocolate icing
flows out of a hopper into applicators
[Music]
they deposit the icing in a swirl onto
the cupcakes adding nearly an inch of
height and a lot more sweetness
[Music]
down the line workers load sugary
sprinkles into another hopper a feeder
dispenses a few more of the sprinkles on
to each of the frosted cupcakes
the containers then ride by a rail that
folds the lids over
a pusher device presses down on the lids
to close them tightly
the containers of many cupcakes then
meet up with a roller that applies the
adhesive-backed labeling
you